foreign
[Music]
my name is Corey Padilla I am the head
of the scientific Affairs at dovetail
genomics and today we're going to be
looking at how the enhancer promoter
interactome drives a neuronal cell
differentiation and helps to
contextualize alzheimer's associated
polymorphisms
so a brief outline of what we're going
to be talking about today we're going to
do a brief introduction into chromatin
confirmation and the interactive data
type then we'll dive into a case study
where we look at cellular
differentiation from ipsc induced potent
stem cell into a neuronal stem cell and
how topology plays a role in driving
that development
um and then we'll end on how you go
about integrating these types of
interactive data into your research
so with that let's get started on our
introduction
so many approaches to genomics today
result in a very linear view of the
genome so here are the the image I'm
showing at the top are genomic variants
that are visualized on a reference
genome where your genome is pretty much
a straight line and you're looking at
how the different genomic components can
be rearranged on that landscape that
linear landscape
the other version of this sort of linear
view
revolves heavily around regulation and
building these
models about how different genes are
turned on and off and how that
regulatory landscape works and this work
has very much been done through not just
DNA sequencing but you know chip seek
attack seek things like that build this
very nice powerful image of the linear
genome
which is great this has opened up uh
like many many discoveries and helped us
build really great models or how
various diseases and how developmental
programs work and things like that but
it's not the full picture
and we know that because genomes are not
organized in a straight line if you
think about the human genome there's
about three meters of DNA in each cell
that has to be compacted inside of a
nucleus right and it's not just kind of
packaged in a random format there is a
hierarchical structure to that starting
with chromosomal territories at the
larger scale in the nucleus if you can
talk about large-scale
um inside of a nucleus and then
um from there it kind of gets clustered
into these open
um enclosed compartments or A and B
compartments where a compartments tend
to be more active are transcriptionally
active and B components are relatively
silent chromatin that don't um that
aren't involved in gene expression and
then Within These two compartments
there's another uh set of compartments
called these tabs or topologically
Associated domains where clusters of
linked function genes kind of get
grouped together through ctcf mediated
chromatin Extrusion and folding and
things like that and then even further
there are chromatin Loops that are often
associated with enhancer promoter
interactions where the enhancer engages
with the promoter and recruits the right
transcriptional transcriptional
Machinery to then kick those genes on
and so
one of the things that we found is that
confirmation this hierarchical folding
really helps us make this leap from this
linear view of the genome into this 3D
folded structure that helps us
understand exactly which enhancer is
engaged with what promoter and how that
can describe
um the regulatory landscape of a of a
genome right and so that 3D structure
that interaction that confirmation we
refer to as the interactome because the
way that we look at these data are
asking what parts of the genome are
interacting with each other and that
interaction frequency is reflected uh in
the the folding that we've seen in
genome
so how do we capture that information
well
um it's through the the world of
Chromatin confirmation capture the the
core workflow of Chromatin confirmation
capture has been around for a long time
this is known as 3C
um there are many uh offshoots that have
come up from that core workflow but the
core workflow was pretty
um stable throughout all the different
flavors so uh you first start with
Crosslink chromatin to fix the the
chromatin and that 3D orientation and
then you go in and fragment that
chromatin historically that's been done
with restriction enzymes and um towards
the end of this talk we'll tell you why
that might not be the best approach and
how you can kind of get a better view of
topology by not using restriction enzyme
to fragment once you have those uh
digested fragments then you go ahead and
tell ends to lidate and how those
ligations occur
um are based on the 3D structure so
you're going to ligate not net not
necessarily what's next to you in linear
space you're going to ligate with
something that's close to you in
three-dimensional space
um and then you reverse those cross
links and what you have left is a
chimeric molecule where that Junction is
reflective of an interaction in in that
3D space between the genome and so like
I said there are many different
offshoots that we could uh take to look
at this uh the two that we're really
going to focus in on today
um are these this high C approach where
you biotin that ligation event you pull
down and then make a sequencing Library
out of that and look at all of the
interactions throughout the genome the
next one is that Chia Pet also known as
high chip approach where we add a
chromatin immunoprecipitation so we're
going to pull down on a protein of
interest and then ask what the
interactome looks like from the
Viewpoint of that particular protein
um and the result of these uh approaches
looks like this so remember that
chimeric molecule that we said that we
put a biotin on
um that's what we're kind of highlighted
in in the circle and that that molecule
when it gets sequenced it has read one
and read two like you would sequence on
an aluminum Lumina instrument in this uh
though where read one aligns to one part
of the genome and read two lines lines
some distance away and that distance
that it aligns away is again reflective
of that folded so we're bringing that in
these contact matrices where each point
in The Matrix represents a read pair
that are two regions of the genome that
are interacting and then the color or
brightness of that spot is reflected of
how many reads are supporting those uh
two loci interacting
and so when we take a look at this in in
real data this is what it looks like
where we can start seeing regions that
are interacting
more substantially with each other than
with other parts of the genome so those
little triangles that you see kind of
close to the x-axis there that's genomic
position
those are tabs those are topologically
associated domains where there are more
interactions within those regions than
across those regions
um so this is how we visualize the
interaction
we can visualize the interactome in
another way by looking at them through
these contact arcs where um at the top
there I'm showing you the read pair
alignment to the reference genome and
then to the bottom left what I'm showing
is how those repairs would reflect in
these contact arcs where you can see a
stronger signal happening between region
one and Region 3 than there is between
region one and region six now this is
equivalent to those contact matrixes
that I'm showing on the bottom right
where again you see the bright spot
that's reflected of more contacts and
the dollar spot's reflective of fewer
contacts
um the the arc visualization is a
Hallmark of highship data that we'll be
getting to later on and the contact
Matrix is more commonly used in things
like high C on the C and microc which is
what we're going to start our case study
on
so now that we all kind of know why we
should be thinking about the 3D genome
why we sh why the interactome kind of
brings that importance to Gene
regulation and how we visualize that
let's dive into our case study here
which is really looking at the uh the
regulatory interactome between an ipsc
cell that's been induced into a neuronal
stem cell
and so I want to start this case study
with a very familiar image this is the
Waddington landscape where at the top
you see that pluripotent stem cell right
that's the one genome that all of the
the cells in our bodies have but as
cells develop or as your body develops
right these cells can kind of get moved
into different valleys into this
Waddington landscape and that's largely
driven by epigenetic changes through
methylation through acetylation through
different types of Chromatin folding
things like that and so as different
epigenetic modifiers occur you can have
that's that one genotype give rise to
many different phenotypes this is
differentiation which we've highlighted
on the arrow on the left hand side of
that image now the other way to think
about it is that you could reprogram
cells by trying to re-induce
pluripotency and having them move back
up the Waddington landscape to the
original pluripotent cell cell type
um but it's this sort of you know model
where you start with one genotype and
through these epigenetic modifications
you can have many different phenotypes
that's kind of the you know the central
dogma of
um uh of development and and how cells
can change from uh one genotype into
these various cell forms
and so the question that we really want
to drive at today is what role does
chromatin confirmation play in
development and cellular differentiation
and so to that end we have this model
where we have induced potent stem cells
and then we have
um then we've forced those ipsc cells to
become neuronal stem cells or nfcs and
so uh and which those nscs can then be
further developed into astrocytes
neurons or oligodendrocytes
and so we're really going to focus in on
the difference between those ipsc those
polar opponent stem cells and the
neuronal stem cells so just the the
kickoff between uh differentiation in to
that neuronal cell type
and to look at this model system we have
generated rna-seq data so we're going to
look at the actual transcriptional
activity of these two cell types we have
chip seek to look at the enhancer
promoter repertoire and some of the key
uh pluripotence latency factors of these
two some uh these two
all types and then we have our Omni C to
be that high C approach
um to look at genome-wide context and
then we're going to dive in to the high
chip which is the protein directed view
of the interactive and finally we're
going to take some g-was data um that's
been linked to alzheimer's and we'll try
to contextualize what those variants are
in terms of the regulatory landscape
which is actually a really exciting
thing to do with this particular data
type so I'm just highlighting here that
it has been shown in previous work that
chromatin interaction changes can
account for a significant portion of uh
cellular differentiation so we really
want to Target our question here about
what's really going on between the ipses
and the nscs
so the first thing we're gonna we're
gonna do is look at the
um the RNA SEC and see what the the
regulatory landscape is between these
two cells so what we have here is a go
analysis of that rna-seq data the
differential expression between the NFC
and ipsc now what I've done is I've
colored
um the the
columns in this Dot Plot to reflect
whether or not they are a developmental
function which is that sort of yellow
orangish color or if there's a specific
specific neuronal um function that's
been upregulated in the nfcs so what we
can see here across the board is that
most of the functions that are up
regulated in the nsc's cells are
associated with either developmental
functions or neuronal functions
um as compared to the ipsc cells which
are mostly just cellular maintenance and
pluripotency maintenance
um which all goes to show that our model
system is in fact behaving as our model
system should right this is just kind of
confirmation
um that our our system is working
properly
the next thing that we wanted to ask is
you know of the key pluripotency
maintenance factors what
um is the activity of those factors
between the two cells so here we're
looking at nanog aqu4 and socks II all
of these are critical to the maintenance
of that stem cell type right where uh it
has the potential to be differentiated
into many different cell types
um and what we can see here is that in
between the ipsc which are the blue
circles and the blue coverage profiles
and uh the NSC which are the red
coverage profiles
um sorry I got I need to post my email
we're gonna have to edit that out
no problem let me go ahead and make a
quick note for editing give me one
second
yeah and I just closed my email so that
won't happen again
my bad no worries one sec okay
definitely were an updated before it
ended
up
and this is just a confirmed slide 14.
yeah I'll take slide 14 from the topic
more seconds
Studio information kind of included last
night okay perfect all right we'll go
ahead and just give it a few seconds and
then you can start at the topic Supply
14.
thank you
okay so the next thing that we wanted to
ask of this uh model system is what is
the activity of the pluripotency
maintenance factors
um between these two cell types so here
we're doing chip seek for Nano or
against nanog opt-4 and Slots too all of
these factors are critical to the
maintenance of the pluripotency so it's
it's all about maintaining that ability
for the ipsc cells to be able to
differentiate into other cell types
um and so what we can see here across
the board
um for each one of these factors is that
in the ipsc cells which is the blue
circle in the blue coverage
um but these factors are fairly active
and highly engaged across the entire
genome whereas in the NSC which is the
red circle in the diagrams or the red
coverage plot that these factors are
pretty much absent or severely reduced
in their activity across the genome so
this is a second piece of confirmation
here that the the system that we're
working in is actually
behave as we expect so I'm breaking here
but it's nice to know that our model
system is behaving like our model system
so the next thing that we really want to
start diving into is how does topology
how does that interact on data type help
us make sense of um what's going on with
these particular factors So to that end
we're going to focus in on nanog just
for the case of this this little case
study here there's a lot more to dive
into but we're going to really narrow
our view here on what's going on with
nanog
and so the first thing that we wanted to
do is ask what is the compartment
structure look like between the ipsc and
the NFC cells now if you remember back
to our initial introduction to
confirmation there is open uh chromatin
which is usually an a compartment or
inactive or silent chromatin which is
normally a b compartment and so what I
have plotted on the left are the a b
compartment scores rather the open
closed squaredness of uh the ipsc and
NSC across chromosome 12. and just
visually looking at these two
um sort of score Maps we can see that
there are differences in how these
matrices actually look but it becomes a
lot clearer when we just look at the
eigenvector which is the key score
across the Matrix that tells us whether
or not it's in an A or B compartment
um across the length of chromosome 12.
so if you move to the right I've blown
up the eigenvector plot there at the
bottom
and I've annotated the y-axis to show if
it's above zero it's an open or active
chromatin score and in the uh if it's
below zero then it's a closed or
inactive score so these regions are
going to be less transcriptionally
active and so what you could see is as
you go along chromosome 12 here that
there are clear shifts between
um the NSC and ipsc cells where there
are regions that uh are open in the ipsc
cells and closed in the um the NSC cells
and vice versa but particularly what I
want to point out here is nanog which is
that dashed line very early on on
chromosome 12. and what we can see is
that
um in the NSC cell type nanog actually
occurs now in silence chromatin where on
the ipsc cells it occurs in an open
chromatin region so that kind of goes to
show that
um
the compartment structure around nanog
already kind of sets us up on the scale
that or on on the notion that
um nanog activity the the transcription
of nanog is going to be severely reduced
in the NFC cells because it occurs in
now A B compartment and now occurs in
that silent chromatin region so next we
wanted to zoom in on the region around
nanog and look at domains what is the
domain structure those tabs those linked
function uh clusters
um particularly around nanog
so first we ask from a genome-wide
standpoint what does the tab structure
look like between the ipscs and NFC
cells so what I have plotted on the left
is just the total number of tests that
have been called at 25 KB resolution
and we can see that ipsc cells contain
more tags right they're uh they're
slightly over four thousand tabs wherein
the nfcs they're um less than four
thousand pounds being called so these
are unique domains
um that are uh that have higher degree
of interactions within the domains
rather than across domains
so what about the size of these domains
is different between these two cell
types so uh the next plot we have the
box and whisker plot is the Tad size in
uh kilobases between the ipsc and NFC
cells and what we can see is on average
the ipsc cells contain smaller Tad sizes
than the nfcs so while NSC sees tab
numbers go down the actual test sizes
increase right so you're getting these
bigger clusters that are encapsulating
more linked function genes within a
domain where that anorectom is going to
be um more frequent and you are seeing
in the NFC which has smaller more broken
down structures and now if we
specifically ask the question what is
the cad structure around nanog
um that's what I have plotted on the
right here where we can see the
interactome that's the heat map for both
ipsc and NFC and the Tad boundaries
which are those blocks that are being
plotted across chromosome 12. and right
where nanog lives which
the dotted line here we can see that
geez there is a tad boundary that flanks
Nano so in um in the ipsc nanog occurs
within a tad and in the NSC uh cell type
that Tad is now missing that domain of
increased interactome is is gone
um so that's you know another line of
evidence here that the topology specific
to nanog is actually quite different
between these two cell types now these
first two lines of evidence are really
great to point at kind of larger
structures in what driving the Nano uh
transcription signal but it doesn't
really tell us too much about what the
specific enhancer promoter interactome
looks like around Nano so now the next
thing that we want to do is zoom in
on uh the the region of the genome that
is really focused in on and on so that's
what we've done here and so we've
plotted out the omni-c data type for the
ipsc which is going to be on the left
and the NSC which is going to be on the
right below that we have the rnac
coverage tracks
um in blue and then in red that's h3k27
acetylation chip seek data for the
enhancers and then ingrained below that
we have h3k4 trimethylation data which
is the active promoter marks um and then
below that we have the genes and so what
I've done in the blue box is uh kind of
called out where the nanog promoter
lives and what I want to point out first
here is that the interactome did on the
top and that contact Matrix what we can
see is that in the ipsc cells there is
an enrichment of context right we see
more bright pixels in the region around
nanog where in the NSC data side we're
not seeing those contexts those context
has pretty much been obliterated
um and then if we go down and look what
we can see is in that blue box as we go
down we can see that nanog is
transcriptionally active in ipsc which
is good we should see that
um and then we see uh that the enhancer
marks
um sorry the promoter marks the bottom
in green there are active in ipsc but
largely missing right there's no
um green spike in that blue box for the
Nano promoter so that promoter is no
longer considered active
moreover what we can do here now is we
can see that in the red box
um through the interactive we can link
the that particular enhancer Mark as
being the strongest interaction with the
Nano promoter in the ipsc and also that
particular enhancer Mark is missing in
the NSC
um data type so through this we can now
actually say not only are the contacts
um are missing between the I uh between
nanog and the enhanced promoter but the
the whole enhancer promoter landscape is
quite different at nanog
um
uh at ipsc than they are at NSC
and so this is really great but the
other thing that we're still kind of
missing here is from the enhancer and
promoter Viewpoint what is really the
key interaction that is being lost here
between the ipsc and NSC and so to
address this we're going to be looking
um at high chip data that's that
protein-directed interactive and as I
mentioned earlier in the core workflow
it's going to start with those
cross-length cells we're going to
perform the fragmentation we use Ms to
do this then we conduct our chromatin
Amino precipitation
with our antibodies then from there we
perform that proximity ligation where we
make those chimeric molecules that are
reflective of that long-range
information reverse those crosslinks in
sequence
the resulting data type here captures
that DNA protein binding site so on the
the blue line I'm showing chipsy data
for ctcf and the green track below that
I'm showing
um High chip data where we're able to
recapitulate those chip seek Peaks and
the highship data and then um below that
we have those contact arcs that I were
describing earlier that shows how these
Peaks are actually interacting with the
surrounding genome so we can see places
of very strong interaction in places of
very weak interaction
so what we've done is we've taken these
ipsc and the NSC cell types and we've
done High chip on these cells for
enhancers promoters and the ctcf
chromatin boundaries
we see when we look at nanox so the
first
two tracks in this um this plot here are
uh h3k27 acetylation this is the
enhancer marks below that ingrained we
have h3k4 trimethylation marks for the
active promoters and then we have ctcf
peaks in red below that and then what
I'm plotting in the track immediately
below that is the log fold change of
gene expression so where the you see
blue blocks those are genes that are
more expressed in ipsc cells than in NSD
cells okay so this kind of seems a
little messy there's a lot going on in
this plot but it's really informative
and I'll show you why
so if we think just about the enhancer
promoter interaction what I've
highlighted here in The Orange Box is
that not only is there a loss of
enhancer enhancers and promoter marks
there is a very specific loss of
interaction between the enhancers and
the promoters at uh the nanog uh
genocide so this is showing us that it's
these particular enhancer marks um so if
you look at the top track
and the h3k27 assemblation we can see
that there's enhancer Mark that has two
arcs being drawn over then if we go down
to the first green track we see a
promoter Mark with two arcs that are
hitting the spot where the enhancer
lives so we can now definitively say
that it is that enhancer that's engaged
with that promoter site and ipsc cells
that's driving the transcription of uh
nanog and then in the ipsc we lose those
contacts so there is an enhancer that
occurs slightly Upstream of nanog but we
can see that that Arc is being forced
away from the Nana promoter so that
enhancer is actually not engaged with
the Nano promoter
um so that's how powerful this data type
is so you might be able to see shifts in
enhancer promoter marks but now you can
actually say which direction those
enhancers or promoters are engaging with
the surrounding genome so even though we
see an enhancer Mark for the NSC near
nanog it's actually not engaged with the
nanog promoter at all
um next if we look at just the chromatin
boundaries these ctcf we can see that in
ipsc right we see that Tad structure the
the loops between the ctcf occurring
that are missing in ipsc and moreover
there are sub Tad boundaries or sub
Loops where those interactions are being
lost in the ipsc so
um if you remember the image that we saw
in the last uh or two slides ago with
the contact Matrix and how those
interactions are just obliterated we now
have confirmation through the cttf
Viewpoint um of that and we also have a
very powerful data type that tells us
exactly what enhancer is engaged with
what promoter to turn nanog on
um so that's really one of the very
powerful things that this data type
brings to the table
and so what we've just done with that
high chip data is essentially we've
annotated what enhancer is engaged with
what promoter now if you're thinking
about an epigenetic standpoint that
that's very powerful but what if you
don't have chip seek data what if you
have a bunch of GEOS information
um and variants that you know are linked
to a disease but you don't know exactly
what they're doing
well this interactive data type is very
powerful to help annotate those geost
bearings and so what we're going to do
is we're going to take the um the NSC uh
chip seek and highship highship data for
enhancers and gwas identified
Alzheimer's Snips so in the blue uh
coverage that I'm plotted here that's uh
enhancer chip c coverage
across chromosome 19 and then below that
in red are the positions of Alzheimer's
Associated sentence
um and in that dotted line where you see
that very strong red signal for the the
variant that is uh those are Snips that
are occurring around app OE which is
known to be a very strongly correlated
with Alzheimer's
and so what we did is we went in and we
we zoomed in on that apoe region and we
plotted the chipseek
um
uh coverage which is what is the first
track of blue coverage in the blow up
and then uh below that we have all the
promoter regions that are occurring um
in that region and I've colored apple E
green
then below that we have the high chip
contact arcs right what is uh what are
the enhancers actually
um engaged with and so if we just ask
the question around the um what what
interactions are occurring with apoe
I've colored those contact arcs green
and so what you can then go is go in and
say what enhancers in that landscape are
actually engaged with apoe
so now what we can do then is go into
the snip data that again those are the
the red cloths or the red bars in the um
the plot at the very bottom
we can now go in and say that any of
these Snips that are occurring over
these um apoe enhancer regions could
actually be engaged with at Poly so even
though it doesn't occur even though
these variants don't occur directly at
the app how we promote our origin body
that they are occurring kilobases away
that these Snips could actually impact
the ability for um that acetylation to
occur and therefore destroy a enhancer
promoter interaction that is critical
for Apple's function so it's you know
taking this interact on data and
applying that enhancer promoter sort of
annotation to snip promoter annotation
and we can actually have a more accurate
view of what these Snips are doing for
disease-length variants
so uh just briefly I want to go over a
summary of the findings that we we've
had so far so uh what we've shown is
that the regulatory programs that drive
neuronal development from these induced
pluripotent stem cells into
um the neuronal cell type can be linked
to both very large scale topology
features and very fine scale topology
features and that of those fine scale
features we can actually go in and
identify the specific enhancer promoter
interactions at nanog that are driving
um the the loss of that transcriptional
uh program in NSC cells that leads to
the loss of pluripotency that allows for
the neuronal cell type to start
developing
um and then you know finally we showed
that the interactome
um expands the ability to annotate these
variants and has actually a large
implication for not just reassigning a
snip but also to maybe rescue some of
these uh the US's these variants of
unknown significance so we know that
many of these variants occur in
non-coding regions well uh we actually
have a means by which we can link those
non-coding regions to coding regions and
when we apply the enhancer Viewpoint or
promoter Viewpoint to those interactions
we can actually start annotating these
variants of unknown significance so it's
a very powerful data type to bring into
your studies
so which leads us to the last part of
this talk which is how do you go about
integrating the interactome into your
research so
here at dovetail
um our core technology that enables us
to do everything from genomic analysis
all the way into the interactive
analysis is this proximity ligation that
core workflow that I talked about in the
introduction where cells are
cross-linked to preserve that 3D
interactome structure we fragment The
genome then we ligate those fragments
back together based on three-dimensional
proximity rather than linear proximity
and then we have that chimeric read
that's biotinylated at that ligation
site we pull down on that molecule and
then we sequence that molecule and then
from there there are a handful of
flavors that you can do from this core
workflow that dovetail supports so our
first
um route is with omni-c now this is an
approach where we fragment the uh the
chromatin using dnas and we do this in a
manner that um gives us very much
uniform coverage of the genome we can
reap recapitulate whole genome
sequencing coverage through the use of
dnase and chromatin fragmentation so
what I have here is the assay the
approach that makes it different from
the other
um uh from that core workflow and what
it results in and so for omni-c what we
have is that whole genome
um sequence coverage that really opens
up uh proximity ligation data to do a
whole genome sequencing things and we'll
talk about that a little bit more in
depth in the upcoming slides our next
approach is microc which we use imminase
to fragment the chromatin and so this
gives us a
mono and dinucleosome fragments that we
can go in and ask about what does the
interactive look like from the Viewpoint
of a nucleosome this is really cool
because it the the nucleosome is the
building blocked chromatin and
conformation works at the scale of
Chromatin so we're able to look at the
interactome from the Viewpoint of a
nucleosome whereas with the omniscient
approach we're asking the Viewpoint of
the anorectum from a single base pair
which is more informative to uh primary
sequence whereas the microcy is more
informative over actual chromatin
building blocks and then finally we have
the height chip which enabled us to
really identify which enhancers were
engaged with what promoters where we
fragment with M and Ace and then we go
in and do the chromatin
immunoprecipitation with an antibody of
choice that gives us that
protein-directed view of the interactom
so um now we're going to go into a
little bit more depth for each one of
these particular products so that
uniform coverage of omnisie captures a
more complete view of topology and
expands the data utility so what I'm
showing here is a workflow where you
take your sample this could be tissue
blood
um
or self material and then you perform
the omni-c assay you sequence the data
and from there you can do structural
variant detection you can do snip and
end out genotyping because we're getting
whole genome um sequencing coverage and
then you can use that information to
reassemble genomes so this is actually
really powerful if you have you know
cancerous genomes and you want to
reassemble the genome instead of
comparing to the hd38 reference you can
build your own reference of your
particular cancer
um and then because we're getting that
whole genome coverage and able to
capture the Snips and and be able to
genotype we can now phase hapotypes so
this becomes really powerful because the
data span very long range information so
you can build a very large phase
haplotype blocks of regions that are
coming from either mom or dad
uh and then finally it can be used for
chromatin confirmation which is what the
Crux of the study that we showed here
today one of the really cool things that
I do want to point out here is that
because we have whole genome-like
coverage in the omni-c assay you can
come in with a hybrid capture panel so
say if you have a pan cancer panel or
you have a particular promoter panel or
you know it really any panel that you
want you can throw that at the omni-c
library pull down and then you don't
have to sequence as deeply to ask very
targeted questions about topology so if
you have questions about that please
feel free to reach out to us we're very
excited about this capability and we
would love to talk to people about it
the next approach like I mentioned was
the microc approach where we fragment
with M A's and now this gives us that
nucleosome-centric view of uh topology
and so what this does is it allows us to
capture the larger topology features
like a b compartments tabs and ctcf
mediated events like we really got into
in that ipsc study but it also allows us
to then zoom in even further on the
building blocks of Chromatin to look at
specific enhancer promoter
um interactions even look at things like
Loop extra
holding
um how how chromatin actually just
engages and folds over top of each other
that really helps regulate them you know
gene expression like the one thing that
pops to my mind is always bivalent
chromatin um it's a very unique aspect
of our genome it's really kind of hard
to get at and you can visualize by
valence um interactions through this
data type very strongly
um not only does it allow us to view
um interactions at a much more finite
resolution but it also has a higher
signal to noise because we're really
stacking data over those nucleosomes so
for the features that you're trying to
identify like uh enhanced promoter
interactions or chromatin looping we're
getting more read support per feature
which is what I've highlighted there in
the contact Matrix so in the circle is a
our Loop calls and then the numbers next
to those Loop calls or the number of
reads that are supporting those
interactions so if you look at different
approaches to to capture so micro C uh
and different restriction enzyme
approaches you can see that you're
missing or you either don't have a lot
of read support for those calls or that
there's features that you're clearly
missing in the contact Matrix because
you're really limiting your Viewpoint to
a restriction site rather than to a
nucleosome
and then finally
um the high chip approach here which is
again really about pulling down and
asked question about the interact home
from the Viewpoint of a protein of
Interest so
um you know the the kind of the big ones
that people tend to go for are h2k4
trimethyl for active promoters ctcf for
chromatin boundaries and then h3k27
acetylation for enhancers so you can ask
the question what is engaged with my
promoter or what is my enhancer engaged
with if you go
um the the methylation or the
acetylation route
and finally you can access all of these
dovetail Solutions through either kits
or services so our omni-c our micro C
and our height chip are all available
through a kit
um that is really easy to use and walks
you from sample prep all the way through
sequencing and then we also have
analytical support
that will help you align the data
process the data and get you to ask your
biological question we don't want you
spending a lot of time thinking about
data processing we want you thinking
heavily about what your biological
question is and how you can address that
and so both our services and our kids
are facilitated through a really great
customer support team and like I
mentioned earlier that computational
guidance I spent a lot of time Computing
these data and it's a lot of fun and I
love talking to people about what it is
that they want to do with the data and
how we can get them there so you know if
you have any questions about that please
don't hesitate to reach out to us
and with that I would like to say thank
you very much for listening in and I'm
will gladly take any of your questions
not only that but I'll be in the booth
so if you have any you know technical
questions or you know biological
questions or if you want to drill down
on the ipsc story and you have some
unanswered questions there no um I'll be
there and and more than happy to answer
any questions or we can set up a meeting
after the uh the conference to discuss
in more detail so whatever works best
for you all and again thank you very
much